ils entendent squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve pour la suite de dredd out
l'acte ii est sorti on a fait des vidéos
dessus il ya des mois et des mois ils
ont mis 4 3 de sortir ce [ __ ] de wella
d'une voix très fort je suis un peu trop
de l'histoire si ce n'est qu'on était
arrivé dans un endroit mégajoule ou avec
nos amis et qu'il y avait des gros
fantôme une source a connu de pouvoir
émane des items collectables très bien
c'est qu'on a un appareil photo qu'on
peut prendre des photos vous souvenez
1,7 million de flacons incarné avec qui
ce faisait maltraiter par tous les
fantômes de la planète ou sauver complet
quel est le fus qui ne fut qu elle s
bruit mais sort de frelons un peu
étrange et nikki m'affoler c'est ça un
quart aux plats souvenirs de vacances ce
sera vraiment tendance montre en as à
nos amis seront tellement dingue
regardez-moi ça sur ce décor
paradisiaque [ __ ] je viens la comédie
française au québec
je me fais pas très d'accord une [ __ ]
de chouettes quoi parlez vous non mais
je me suis emmerdé
mais qu'est-ce que ça que ça laissez moi
[ __ ] on dirait des radis qui bouge
ah mais je me fais mal traités par des
trucs qui font la taille de mon pied
à partir de là on peut plus rien faire
pour cette femme que je me bats pour que
voir par là non mais qu est-ce que les
des bois tuer
j'arrive coup de balayette ok je fais me
touche et me torcher métaux par ou pour
vous nous passez par le bus made by yes
made in not made by not as a carrément à
sa part sur un village de téléphone
sortie c'est quoi c'est truc mec les
regards des bois de ça alors où sont mes
copains j'aimerais trouver un copain
mais il suffisait de demander
[ __ ] mais c'est ça qu'on veut au lac
étals francisco comment l'as tu as à
temps qu'est ce qu'il fait ou là je
m'éloigne un peu j'ai un peu peur quand
même
one of my gym de télépathe monga j'étais
en être un il suit la foire il marche
vraiment moche mans par où je dois aller
mais on fasse ma roue par là tous droits
viennent sur deux bungalows ou continue
bonsoir oui il est tombé ou laminé ce
qu'ils étaient forts les permis au sua
ok mais on ne peut passer par la mer est
à la hausse et ce qu tu vas tu es
francis côté constant et ton mentor cela
il faut une attelle
[ __ ] on se retrouve là à les voyages
[ __ ] c'est pas le temps tu touches un
système adapté sa charge à rien de faire
ça je te rassure il va jeter faux
esquivé on dirait qu'on copule carrément
teint vous faut aller là on peut pas
aller là là là oui on peut y aller ben
voilà [ __ ] mais montrer le nous et
faire bien cette porte quadruple tôt
s'il te plaît voilà le par a + ça lui
fera mal ah non ah ça c'est quoi double
tour pour toi on pourra mettre des coups
de parapluie comme ça et
avant j'espère ne pas recroiser les
petits taux baissent de 2 cm comme les
plus petites aux baisses du monde et
quoi là dedans
oh mon dieu un objets ramassés de cet
objet man une énergie mystérieuse
bonjour j'aimerais retrouver mon
téléphone
quel est ce weel bordel lui ce thème on
défonce vous le dis non dans ce cas
mange mes fesses à temps il a ça m'a
accroché à la porte comme pour la
défonce et bien sûr que l'on n'a pas
rappelé on va pas croire qu'il sorte non
plus là ce serait magnifique ce serait
apocalyptique c'est pour la rime
uniquement alors qu'ici on trouve par
ici c'est des stands de nourriture c'est
passionnant c'est fade birao thématiques
il est là aux annonces à la casse et
j'ai cru qu'ils étaient flex et tout
mais non halal à regarder se cambre
écrit le sait le démon est un piège ah
c'est pas très bien fait est là pour le
coup allez on avance pourquoi paniquer à
aller au monde qui a person is it shake
dat ass shake dat ass ça fait faire
pervers en monture lui aussi marc legros
qu un nom il est tombé sans faire exprès
harry morton bon comme ça et du coup on
ressort mais oui c'est un véritable
cache cache roman mon téléphone rôle à
moi s'il te plaît à le [ __ ] alors lui
comprend absolument rien il s'est fait
une entorse de plus non mais laisse moi
moment là comme l'apport d'air toi elle
n'a pas fermé battant mais cette maison
est en polystyrène
ça devient ridicule
ah mon dieu oh quelle position
incroyable excusez moi mais c'est
vraiment la scène la scène de figure à
la prise à croyable que j'ai vu quand
est ce qu'ils vivent
[ __ ] mais les talons hauts du conte et
chats allez on s'en va en entendant son
nom vient de la baader toi à la fin la
home ont tué nous attraper il va falloir
se pâmer touche non qu'est ce qui se
passe à le démon rentrant mois battant
des mains elle a fait disparaître elle
magicienne franck huette la magicienne
et alors le démon breton dans le corps
du mec elle leur manipule ça y est en
route du jeu à temps mais c'est ça pour
ça que c'est les mettre à deux pour été
capelle dans une ville abandonnée là
et c'est la fin merci à leur gardien
jaunes ont jailli ghost une blague ah
ben voilà il y en a un vrai appareil
photo qui prend des photos c'est le
petit haut ça fait peur ça nous avons
trouvé un slr russe s'est pas nicole c1
miron attention l'avançon craint rien ni
personne on a le nieront photo photo
photo portrait qu'elle sp dilbeek
il a le pays le plus large du monde a
été trop fort foule de photographes et
plein de fois vous avez trouvé le sac de
linda mais voilà on a trouvé une bague
de cet objet ces mannes de l'énergie
mystérieuse cherchons d'abord lu cette
phrase pendant 20 ans aux docks où on
est là et plus jamais ça le coq chantant
derrière il ya des gens qui rigole est
ce que c'est le reste de mes et de mes
copains ou alors est ce que c'est les
restes de corps assez pas le même raisin
coup les restes d'hier soir à manger on
avait fait du poulet dans une houle ont
dieu photo direct est un bonhomme aux
mondiaux mais c'est hyper sensuel et si
mon personnage féminin donc ça passe
mieux si on était un homme et nous
auraient jamais tous des ae des high
kick et des claques
ça va au quartz est le pays des femmes
vous êtes toute jolie est belle surtout
toi je parle à tous à toi crient les
rigoles on s'amuse à cali ces divinités
à temps mais là ça part en mediastay
classe à part à sa part hamburger
carrément au lycée j'adore les pieds
quoique si vous faire à la fois ouest un
super détour à bientôt tout le monde
juste et fantastic art prends le couteau
vous avez trouvé qu'elle est de cet
objet ses mains de l'énergie la photo de
groupe fait un sourire oh mon dieu des
pieds financement les pieds quel est le
poids qu'il botte d'un serpent qui
volent à bas quand même
il fait juste mais je crois qu'ils vous
téléporter quelque part c'est la
pataugeoire
c'est le petit bassin pour les enfants
aux trois bougies d'un coup what you go
now le chemin s'ouvre c'est parti aux
mondiaux ça sera mon regard des
attentions 3 dehors ça devait arriver
dégueulasse oh on est à ça plus touché
le pays en mon dieu elle est si divine à
l émoi divine dacquois au bon dieu
allait vraiment dégueulasse finalement
on dirait une sorte de monstre en
camisole à mon dieu mon dieu mon dieu
mon dieu mon dieu arrange tamar battant
rennes elle peut pas bouger à quoi on a
juste à faire ça en boucle
hop là haut je prends en photo tout ce
qui bouge m'en bats les stocks sont des
professionnels on l'est pas et damien
coup en fait ok je vois on met les pieds
on met les pieds dans le sac là et on
fait une course c'est comme ça que ça se
passe ici allez vulgaire sac de couchage
mouret et en photographie lie à mon dieu
elle en train de décider a répondu elle
m'a attrapé alors mabrouk est quand même
à la photo la photo
oui j'ai percé la focus [ __ ] moi si tu
pouvais te flash pardon c'est un des
deux mais je dois faire droit péta je me
suis cognée fallait toucher à rien et
ont gagné en ajoutant quelques un peu à
tort je suis venu carrément en arrière
maintenant regarder à quelqu'un qui
pleure pour ici on fait tous car je n'ai
trouvé aucun ami depuis vingt ans j'ai
retrouvé mon sac ça par contre j'étais
la plus heureuse du monde à mon dieu ah
ça c'est là le grossiste et du monsieur
on a vu tout à l'heure on le reconnaît
ah bah non c'est quelqu'un qui pleure ou
était dessus où sont les autres tu es
seul à ya du bruit qui vient de là bas
une main à mon dieu oh c'est une boutade
ou lc je crois c'est la doyenne un peu
du groupe
alors je dois faire quoi je dois aller à
la recherche de l'autre là c'est ça ça
lui ira veux tu m'écoutes et non tu pars
en courant c'est marrant ils râlent et
même avis que moi et il rate est
irrattrapable quoi j'en peux plus je
vous le dis je suis à bout montre toi
ira à te voilà qu'elle fait est que veux
tu que cette poupée ira à lire à part de
moi tu peux tu me dire quels sont tes
petits problèmes
kouao ya un fantôme qui m'a fait la
blague du je te tire la chaise au moins
tu t'assois binta te voilà enfin
quelqu'un à qui parler
elle dit que cet endroit est ennuyeux
qu'on devrait jouer à plein de trucs
jean pierre feuille ciseaux quétu je
suis ira j'ai toujours été iras tu ne
reconnais pas ta bonne amie non tu n'es
pas ira sérieusement c'est moi irak et
s'il a pas avec toi et regarde c'est mon
ami suzy dit bonjour à suzy ouais c'est
ton ami quitte à posséder du or not here
ah non je veux être ira maintenant
non tu ne peux pas
je te déteste bah oui j'ai bien
l'intention de te faire chier à elle a
dit qu'elle me quitte alors ok ce qui se
passe en s'est clos aux mondiaux il va
lui je crois de loi et voilà vernet à
cette fois en on ira est décédé au nom
ce fou j'ai fait mon deuil ses bourreaux
longchamp powell volet sur cydia fin de
cette première partie de dresde à au
tchèque 3-2 n'hésitez pas aimé les deux
ça vous a plu en tout cas c'est assez
long et on fait des points on sait plus
trop s'il faut faire c'est très mal
indiqué le coût du boss qui tschopp et
il faut appeler sur rien pour rester en
vie qui est calé le fup mais ça vous
regarde et on se retrouve très vite dans
une nouvelle vidéo et dans la partie ii
un de ces quatre châteaux en pis
c'est ça quand on est doué c'est ça
qu'on est tous et au central avait 4